[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and
you've been here over 10 minutes and
haven't had any alcohol yet i know
i think people are going to be blown
away call bobby
bobby
you think he'll answer yeah
what if it weren't a ring
[Laughter]
give it up for the fattest and most
racist comedian working today
bert kreischer all right man oh what an
intro i can't wait to see what what
moniker i add on to that today
accidentally
you get a lot of comments like that oh
yeah they're so much fun
there's so much fun this is the most
[ __ ]
exhausting because
you have no idea because you ever have
people like like your dad or your wife
going why are people saying you're
racist
my agents
promoters yes everyone has said hey man
we're getting a lot of feedback that
you're racist
and is that what you bring to the show
i don't know not at all as my [ __ ]
[ __ ] friend tom started it as a lark
and i [ __ ] hit it out of the park
by the way hey if uh if you're my friend
and you're in recovery don't hit me up
i'm not in recovery okay like i don't i
don't plan i'm not going to a [ __ ]
meeting and i don't want to go to lunch
with you like i don't want to sit and
talk about sober stuff i'm a regular
[ __ ] person
like they're not regular people no no
but i don't want to talk like sober talk
the body shots world tour
no blacks allowed
that's i did not make that that is not
sanctioned crazy i know i'm gonna spend
this whole podcast just going okay
that's not real
do what's awful is when when people
comment on it yeah in the comment
section yeah oh burt this is
uh you're such a fat racist [ __ ]
and then
and then new fans that have just found
me from netflix defend me yeah they're
like he's a good guy he's a it's a joke
and there's no racist joke right i don't
even have a racist joke in my act yeah
and there's nothing there and they're
like it's jokes if you can't learn how
to take a joke he makes fun of everyone
equally i'm like i'm not thinking about
anybody it's a picture of my daughter
hey
hey
oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
what happened oh my god tommy tom uh
bobby just hopped up what looks like a
tonsil stone that's
that's no [ __ ] i'm not kidding it's
the size of like an m m hey
that's huge it's on your table it's
gonna stay there oh
listen
what's up rudy just [ __ ] won an oscar
she's got chops she's an actor man she's
an actor
like we we know how dope she is by the
way yeah uh the crew over here is loving
us and
uh us like this is a completely
different level guys a new level
[Laughter]
can we dump it down a bit you know yeah
you should you should
uh
nikov said slow down a little bit yeah
you guys are crushing way too hard for
the time like he's like usually uh
hey tell them if they're having a good
time do two episodes yeah yeah hey
listen
we need to bank some shows go ahead and
do a second for us
good call
hey but i feel like rudy's 10 times the
actor bobby is i feel like it's going to
cause some problems at home oh his face
just dropped his face
oh my god oh my god dude
no he's stretching his face but wait why
why doesn't he nervous when he touches
his face
when he gets sad he touches his face why
doesn't he ask her for help when he has
auditions and stuff she's she's a
natural accent queen oh dude you're
getting him he's touching the mic
oh what was horrible sanitize
he's saying pretty racist [ __ ] but just
give him a
second yeah bobby says he wants to poop
on the table oh that sounds like a bobby
move oh man that'd be great it's so fun
doing this it's a really good idea
i'm so glad we switched to you why the
[ __ ]
jesus
sanitize the mice please
sanitize the mics he said first of all
you guys got corona that's true now i
already had it yep bobby is impervious
to it how's the impervious
because you know they say if you're
his blood type is soy sauce they can't
get it like i always been a pretty big
boy but it really got off the rails when
she got pregnant yeah it really was we
would go out to uh we would go out to go
to breakfast like every day oh and we'd
always be like gotta have dessert for
breakfast so i would you were you
you're the one that i that i don't think
people have it in their memory of how
big you were yeah
how big were you at your biggest well
what triggered like when i remember
you know you have like a weight you're
comfortable with so i remember being
like thinking that like 2 45 for
whatever reason was fine yeah and then
at 2 55 i remember just being like yeah
but that's like 245.
yeah my therapist says i like to shave
the hard corners off the truth yeah yeah
so like if somebody said like how much
do you weigh when i play 255 i would say
245 yeah and in my mind i'd be like
that's not really a lie because i'm like
within in your mind you're 245. and then
i can actually remember getting on
scales and seeing like 258 and 261 yeah
and like i remember when it was when
once it's crossed 260 i was like you're
definitely not close 245 anymore no more
scales
wait till your eulogy it's going to be
really special i can't wait now are you
guys going to podcast as i leave are you
going to end it we're going to end it oh
that's classy i hate like when one guy
leaves then they go on for another hour
and a half no no no we're gonna end it
sound like a bad date uh i will just say
that and tom and i will say this to you
there's the last thing i'm gonna say is
that your
your stand up your sk especially
specifically skanks for the memories is
still shorthand dialogue in our house
really oh dude it's not even the jokes
it's the your throwaways like my wife
still will say
did everyone get it that's going to get
it let's move on and i said to georgia
when she was in bed she's sick i said
you know what mom says i want to sound
like a boot stuck in mud only wetter and
she goes yeah what is that and i know
the guy that wrote that's coming over
and georgia goes
there's a guy that wrote that and i went
yeah
we still don't say puppies we say pu
uppies yeah from watching you do a set
yeah some of these jokes should have
really been ringtones i think i would
have made more money and been out of
this game by now
haiti where it rains aids and uh
all right guys let's not ruin it for the
uh for the pandora fan base
burke chrysler's fat it is
where did you get that from uh i found
it that's you saying it yeah that's you
saying it you said it in a phone call
well you were doing uh press somewhere
and they're like what's going on and
then you you said oh yeah i remember
that that's right
is that that's is that right when i was
doing a huge press tour to like 140
radio stations yes i think so and all of
your fans changed my wikipedia page
where chrysler likes digging holes and
eating worms yeah yeah and you know what
to open this show
you know this guy took that interview
and he made
his name is gaping dad and he made an
amazing song out of it i don't know if
you've ever heard it but here's just a
po i won't play the whole thing again
but here's a a portion of it this guy
took that interview i'm just serious
like at the skill level of some of the i
have none of those fans by the way
no one ever i i no one ever no one ever
makes me songs no one ever makes me
pictures like everyone talks about oh my
fans made this great artwork and i'm
like wait i thought we all have the same
[ __ ] fans
when i talk [ __ ] to people when i'm
drunk and i know there's probably a
camera on me
oh sure yeah like that happened at the
mall of america yeah i totally the guy
was like i hit the button they closed
the hotel at 2 12.
and they closed the hotel and so i hit
the button and the guy
are you handicapped i was like what
he's like are you handicapped i was like
no he was like then i can't let you in i
was like oh never mind i'm handicapped
but i did this whole spiel about being
handicapped and then having a blind guy
in a guy in a wheelchair with me but i
was like because the speaker thing was
here so i was like bending down to do
the speaker voice and uh
i got i came around the corner and the
next like the guy was like are you the
guy with the handicap guys
i was like yeah have you seen them
and then he he was like he's like we
have video cameras man
and i was like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] sweating
i gotta take this [ __ ] shirt off okay
oh my daughter's gonna put this on it's
gonna smell like [ __ ] armpits what
this shirt is a small why are you gonna
put it on because it's hers oh it's not
my shirt i where i define my daughter's
shirts like bobby puts on her shirt
like i'd see him but i'd be like i'm not
fat but i really was yeah that and i was
doing that weight loss challenge at the
time i was challenging myself to on i
was doing a vlog and you guys watched it
and you're like what the [ __ ] are you
doing a vlog for what are you 13. yeah
wait this is once it started though once
we started challenging you no i think it
was right before that i think you saw
that too remember when he started doing
vlogs it was when i was pregnant with
ellis yeah and we all had dinner and
he's like look at this vlog oh that's
right and you guys were like yeah i
remember you've been like broken
seriously
yeah because it was at dinner yeah
yeah oh before we move any further this
is a fart mic if you have to fart go
ahead and let us know and we'll hand it
over uh the way my body's reacting i'll
probably ship my pants yeah oh
interesting okay your mom's house is
exclusive yeah because
this is shart week and we were going to
ask you if you have any excellent shirts
i started on my bus over the weekend i
started in bed with leanne yesterday in
vegas
no pants on shorted onto the sheets
and then had to run you know like
tippy-toe it into the bathroom and then
just rifled it out
hold on i'm gonna throw the night before
that's so nasty yeah just you tell you
i was i was vegan for a while
for a
a while everyone has this kind of
subjective roughly three days okay
roughly three days with a few cheap
meals
that's a good run i didn't know this is
part of that wait i told you the health
book you're writing no we were i was
drunk at an airport it sounded like you
were going to vomit right now
i was drunk at an airport and i'm
[ __ ] sweating now yeah i was drunk at
an airport and i was like i bet i could
go [ __ ] vegan and they're like you
couldn't go vegan i go yeah i can do it
everything i put my mind to yeah and so
we get on the plane and i'm like [ __ ]
i'm going vegan i'm going to lose some
weight and go vegan
so i'm drinking a double teeth and soda
she brings me a beer with it
and then lunch comes around and i go
what do you have meat and pasta is there
any cheese on the pasta and she goes no
i said is there any meat on the pasta
she goes no i said i'll go with the
pasta so the guy next to me is kind of
watching me he gets the meat and we
start eating and he goes hey
are you like allergic to cheese i go no
i'm vegan
and he goes really i said yeah he goes
you know there's egg and pasta right
and i go and i didn't know that
he goes how long have you been eating
pasta i go my whole life
and you call yourself vegan this is
what's wrong with you people and he
started [ __ ] jumping into my
lifestyle choice on an airplane choice
by the way he didn't know i've only been
vegan for like 45 minutes
and you don't tell him
i just kept eating the pasta
and then ordered an ice cream sundae
i'll think of the sugar as a reward so
i'll be like i haven't had like a
a real sweet treat in a while
and then
what happens is that like so there's
this bill buildup and anticipation for
it
and then when i have like even part of
it i'm like sometimes i'm like this is
good but i i don't want the whole thing
anymore like i just don't want to go
peggy on it no because part of it is
that like
the it's not as good as you imagine it's
going to be and part of it makes me feel
like yeah that's i'm not that way with
alcohol no no when i build it up and i
have it i go it's just as good as i
remember
but that's different because like i feel
like
a butt like a real alcohol buzz is
really going to make somebody feel good
early morning beer buzz is like one of
my favorite things in the world
don't understand that
i don't know what you're talking about
never had one all right that was a good
episode i think yeah it was a lot of
thank you for being a bad friend
is that how it ends yeah hang on let me
let me make sure we've covered all the
subjects
we didn't sing a song let's [ __ ] go
we didn't sing a song we should sing one
song why
um
what's up what's a good what's a good
song that incorporates
bad friends daddy why you die oh yeah
daddy while you die what's that song
that's it you don't know daddy why you
died
[Music]
we'll sing it
[Music]
i love this i love this i love this all
right yeah have you guys ever have you
ever heard the song elephant in my
backyard
i think you could probably sing along
okay go
there's an
elephant in my backyard
it won't stop honking
and come on
round and round
[Music]
[Music]
telephone
books
okay have you guys ever heard the song i
went fishing and guess what i caught
okay here we go here we go you ready
ready
i think you know at the beginning oh i
went fishing
i caught a
telephone
telephone
and it was on
i want to sing this song i want to sing
this song
let me tell you why i love you okay
okay ready
oh
let me tell you why i love you
it's your eyes
[Music]
by the way this is so much [ __ ] fun
wait you do a song to me okay you do a
song to me what's the name of the song
um anime
the name of the song is anime okay okay
all right here we go let's start it off
how does it start with ready
[Applause]
and they're so petited
[Music]
okay
look into your camera god dammit
we're good
together
because of their big eyes
did you think i was gonna guess that
you think i'm watching them
you know we both watch enemies
we were talking about slut-shaming
because georgia was talking saying about
son about her friends
uh i said something she fell and i was
like oh baby she's crying i go baby why
are you crying you're she's like
everyone likes isla better than me and i
was like no you're beautiful you're cool
she's like dad i'm not cool i don't know
you are cool she goes dad i'm actually
not cool at school all the cool girls
have at least three boyfriends i go oh
no those are [ __ ] baby
there's [ __ ] there's nothing like sunday
dinner in the american culture nothing
like it nothing like sunday dinner in
the american culture i gotta ask you we
spit in it
and then when everything goes sour we
sit there
i don't know what happened
we disrespected our own culture
sunday is that's it i don't listen i
don't give away last night listen i'm
not doing the midnight show i got [ __ ]
to do in the morning when i get there my
kids don't understand that i made the
midnight show they don't understand that
i work and that this is provided they
don't understand that concept you know
what they understand daddy wasn't there
on sunday
that's all and this is what i know from
blowing a marriage and blowing a
relationship and blowing a relationship
with my child i'm not talking out of my
ass and this is what i've seen over the
years through other comics because
there's no woman as much as she loves
their kids when you're calling me going
i'm in beirut dancing with a bunch of
[ __ ] girls
and she's at home at an art class with
[ __ ] isla getting thrown [ __ ] m
m's to the [ __ ] neck
you understand me and you're telling her
how much can a woman tolerate that how
long will you tolerate that at home you
know i'm in puerto rico with three
natives drinking pina coladas wait till
you see me on trip tank and here i am at
home with [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm gonna piss myself where's
[ __ ] what's his name
memorial day weekend guys
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]